يواصلوا الامريكيون التصويت في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونغرس وفتحت مراكز
الاقتراع في الساحل الشرقيه او ابوابها
منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر لكن متى يمكننا
معرفه اي حزم باتبيده الاغلبيه
بعد اذلاء الناخبيننا لاصواتهم اليوم
مقادير يستغرق انتظار النتائج ليله طويله
وربما ايام قبل ان يتضح ما اذا كان
الجمهوريون او الديمقراطيون هم من فازوا
وسيطروا على الكونجرس يتوقع كثيرون موجه
ضخمه من الدعم للحزب الجمهوريه وضغط كبير
من الرئيس السابق ترامب وهو ما يمكن ان
تؤدي الى او يؤدي الى اعلان الجمهوريين
النصر بعد ساعات من اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع
لكن عدت ولايات رئيسيه مثل سلفانيا سبقت
هذا الامر بالاعلان عن ان اي فرز ذلك كل
البطاقات الاقتراع قد يستغرق اياما هناك
مساله اخرى وهي التصويت عبر البريد بعض
الولايات تفرز صناديقها مبكرا قبل يوم
الانتخابات ما قد يرجح كافه حزب على حزب
الاخر وبعض ولايات اخرى لا تبدا العد الا
في نفس يوم الانتخابات لذا فرز وتحديد
الاصوات بالبريد عمليه قد تستغرق اياما
فاينل